i wanted to show them something that  wasn't an illusion  something that was real  something that we could  see and touch  creation  is an act of sheer will  life  will find a way  we can't keep her here forever  they find her we're never gonna see her  again we gotta protect her that's our  job  humans and dinosaurs can't coexist  we created an ecological disaster  ellie settler  alan grant  you didn't come out all this way just to  catch up now did you  you coming or what  [Music]  we're racing toward the extinction of  our species  we not only lack dominion over nature  we're subordinate to it  [Music]  come back i always come back  that's another plane right  not exactly  don't move  bigger why do they always have to go  bigger  [Music]  [Music]  you